Quantenverschränkung erlaubt es Teilchen, unabhängig vom Abstand zwischen ihnen verbunden zu sein. Das ist so kontraintuitiv,
dass nicht einmal Einstein es für wahr hielt. In der heutigen Folge von Qiskit in der Classroom werden wir darüber sprechen, wie Bells
Theorem bewies, dass Einstein
falsch lag. Willkommen bei Qiskit in der Classroom. In dieser Serie nutzen wir Qiskit, um einige grundlegende Konzepte zu erkunden, die häufig
in Kursen zum Thema Quantum Computing behandelt werden. Jedes Video wird auch von einem interaktiven Modul begleitet,
das in der Beschreibung verlinkt ist, also schau da unbedingt rein. Im Quantum-Coins-Video haben wir besprochen, wie das Messen einer
Quantensuperposition ein inhärent probabilistischer Prozess ist, ähnlich wie das Werfen einer Münze. Aber woher wissen wir
das? Könnte es sein, dass ein Quantenteilchen heimlich ein vorbestimmtes Messergebnis verbirgt, das wir jedoch nicht
in unserer Theorie erfassen? In den frühen Tagen der Quantenmechanik war diese Frage Gegenstand
hitziger Debatten mit zwei Hauptlagern. In einem Lager war Einstein, der glaubte, die Quantenmechanik sei unvollständig —
das heißt, dass ihr einige Variablen fehlten, die notwendig waren, um ein System vollständig zu beschreiben. Einstein dachte, dass
diese sogenannten verborgenen Variablen, wenn sie gefunden würden, einige der scheinbar paradoxen und probabilistischen
Aspekte der Quantenmechanik auflösen würden. Im anderen Lager war Max Born. Born argumentierte,
dass die probabilistische Beschreibung der Quantenmechanik alles ist, was von der Natur vorgegeben wird. Anders gesagt:
Es ist nicht nur so, dass wir den Zustand eines Teilchens vor der Messung nicht kennen — das Teilchen hat keinen definierten Zustand,
bevor es gemessen wird. Jahrzehntelang dachten viele, diese Meinungsverschiedenheit sei eine philosophische Frage, die vielleicht nie
gelöst werden könnte. Denn um irgendetwas über ein System zu erfahren, müssen wir es messen. Wie können wir möglicherweise etwas
über die Natur eines Zustands vor seiner Messung erfahren? Dann fand der Physiker
John Bell 1964 einen Weg. In seiner Arbeit untersuchte Bell die statistischen Korrelationen zwischen Messungen eines Paares
verschränkter Teilchen. Wenn die Zustände der Teilchen vor der Messung durch irgendwelche unbekannten verborgenen
Variablen bestimmt wären, dann fand Bell, dass ihre Korrelationen eine Obergrenze hätten. Andererseits, als er die
von der Quantenmechanik vorhergesagten Korrelationen berechnete, stellte er fest, dass sie diese Grenze verletzten. Also hatte er einen Weg gefunden, ein für
alle Mal zwischen Einsteins und Borns Ansicht zu unterscheiden. Alles was noch fehlte, war es, diese Korrelationen tatsächlich experimentell
mit echten Teilchen zu testen, um zu sehen, ob sie der Statistik der verborgenen Variablen gehorchten oder
diese Regel verletzten. Diese Tests wurden mit zunehmender Präzision und Raffinesse
über die Jahre durchgeführt, und sie gehören zu den bedeutendsten Experimenten der modernen Physik. Sie waren so bahnbrechend, dass
sie drei Physikern den Nobelpreis im Jahr 2022 einbrachten. Aber heutzutage kann jeder einen
Bell-Test durchführen. Alles was wir brauchen ist ein wenig Wissen über Qiskit und Zugang zu einem IBM Quantencomputer. In diesem Video werde
ich dich durch die Logik von Bells Ungleichung führen. Dann zeige ich dir, wie wir Bells Vorhersagen auf einem IBM
Quantencomputer testen können. Bells Ungleichung beinhaltet einige verschiedene Messungen und Logikebenen und es kann
etwas knifflig sein zu folgen, aber wir gehen es Schritt für Schritt durch, und am Ende wird es sich lohnen. Wir werden gleich zeigen,
dass Verschränkung real ist und Einstein falsch lag. Das können nicht viele Leute von sich behaupten. Also hier ist,
was Bell vorschlug. Sagen wir, du hast eine Möglichkeit, viele Kopien eines verschränkten Teilchenpaares zu erzeugen. Physikalisch
könnten diese Paare durch einen Zerfallsprozess erzeugt werden, bei dem ein Teilchen in zwei zerfällt. Wenn du das Video über das
Stern-Gerlach-Experiment gesehen hast, weißt du, dass Teilchen einen intrinsischen Drehimpuls namens
Spin haben können. Sagen wir, ein Spin-Null-Teilchen zerfällt in zwei Spin-1/2-
Teilchen. Dann kann jedes der Spin-1/2-Teilchen als Spin plus 1/2 oder minus
1/2 gemessen werden, auch Spin up oder Spin down genannt. Aber da sie aus einem Spin-Null-Teilchen zerfielen, müssen die beiden zusammen
einen Gesamtspin von null ergeben. Also wenn eines als up gemessen wird, muss das andere
down sein und umgekehrt. Diese Teilchen bilden ein verschränktes Paar, das so aussieht.
Also wenn eines als up gemessen wird, ist das andere down, und umgekehrt. Sagen wir, Teilchen eins fliegt nach links oder
in die negative X-Richtung davon, wo ein Forscher, den wir Lucas nennen, seinen
Spin misst. Dann fliegt Teilchen zwei entsprechend nach rechts davon,
wo eine andere Forscherin, Rihanna, diesen Spin messen kann. Lucas und Rihanna können unabhängig
ihre Messgeräte drehen, um den Spin ihrer jeweiligen Teilchen entlang einer beliebigen Richtung senkrecht zur Bewegungsrichtung der Teilchen zu messen.
Wenn wir viele Kopien des verschränkten Zustands an Lucas
und Rihanna senden, können sie Messstatistiken sammeln. Wenn sie immer entlang derselben Achse messen, wird diese Statistik nicht
sehr interessant sein. Jedes Mal misst einer Spin up, der andere Spin down, und jedes Mal misst einer Spin
vorwärts, der andere Spin rückwärts, und so weiter. Aber wenn die beiden Forscher entlang verschiedener Achsen messen, finden wir vielleicht
etwas Interessanteres. Geben wir Lucas und Rihanna drei Achsen, entlang derer sie
messen können. Wir nennen diese Achsen A, B und C, und sie sind jeweils um
120° voneinander getrennt. Die Frage, die wir mit diesem Experiment stellen, ist: Wenn Lucas und Rihanna frei sind, entlang einer der drei
Achsen zu messen, wie oft werden die beiden dasselbe Vorzeichen erhalten? Wenn Lucas und Rihanna zufällig entlang derselben Achse messen,
sagen wir Achse A, können sie nie dasselbe Vorzeichen bekommen, da die Teilchen zusammen Spin null ergeben müssen. Aber wenn sie
verschiedene Achsen wählen, wie werden ihre Messungen korreliert sein, wenn überhaupt? Laut Einstein ist diese quanten-
mechanische Beschreibung des Teilchenzustands unvollständig. Er dachte, es müssten verborgene Variablen existieren, die
das Ergebnis aller möglichen Spin-Messungen vorbestimmen, denn ohne das müssten verschränkte Teilchen
irgendwie das Ergebnis ihrer Messung instantan zueinander kommunizieren. Wenn eines als
up gemessen wird, weit weg hier, muss das andere instantan wissen, dass es dort drüben
down sein soll. Diese verborgenen Variablen könnten eine beliebig komplizierte Anweisungsmenge für das Ergebnis von Experimenten sein, aber der Punkt ist,
dass der Spin-Zustand jedes Teilchens einzeln bestimmt ist, also keine Kommunikation nötig ist.
Experimentell würde das bedeuten, dass Messungen von Lucas keinen Einfluss auf Rihannas Teilchen hätten und umgekehrt.
Das könnte einige Grenzen dafür setzen, wie korreliert die beiden Messungen sein können. Laut Born aber beschreibt dieser Zustand
Psi alles, was vor der Messung über das Teilchenpaar gesagt werden kann. Also beeinflusst die Messung eines Teilchens
das Ergebnis der Messung des anderen. Das kann andere Implikationen für die Korrelationen zwischen Messungen haben. Schauen wir, wie jede
Theorie diese Korrelationen beeinflusst. In der Behandlung mit verborgenen Variablen gibt es eine geheime Anweisungsmenge vor
der Messung, die bereits bestimmt, was Lucas entlang jeder der drei Achsen messen wird. Zum Beispiel könnten
diese Anweisungen lauten: positiv, wenn Lucas entlang Achse A misst,
positiv, wenn er entlang B misst, und negativ, wenn er entlang C misst. Wir können
das schreiben als Plus A, Plus B und Minus C. Dann hätte Rihannas Teilchen
die Variablen Minus A, Minus B und Plus C, damit der Gesamt-
Spin entlang jeder einzelnen Richtung null ist.
Es gibt acht mögliche Anweisungssätze, die diese Spin-Null-Bedingung erfüllen. Also könnte jedes Mal, wenn ein neues Paar
Teilchen an Lucas und Rihanna geschickt wird, eines dieser acht Anweisungssätze enthalten sein. Also wollen wir jetzt
herausfinden — unter der Annahme, die Teilchen enthalten einen der geheimen Anweisungssätze aus der Tabelle und
unter der Annahme, dass Lucas und Rihanna jeweils unabhängig wählen, entlang welcher der drei Achsen sie messen — wie groß ist die
Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass beide dasselbe Vorzeichen messen? Wenn die Anweisungen die aus Zeile 1 oder
8 sind, ist diese Wahrscheinlichkeit offensichtlich null, da die beiden Teilchen unabhängig von ihren
Messachsen entgegengesetzte Vorzeichen haben werden. Aber was ist mit den Anweisungen in Zeile zwei? Sie würden dasselbe Vorzeichen messen, wenn
Rihanna entlang C misst und Lucas entlang A oder B, oder wenn Lucas
entlang C misst und Rihanna entlang A oder B. Das sind also vier von neun
möglichen Messkombinationen, die Lucas und Rihanna dasselbe Vorzeichen geben. Wenn wir das für
jeden Anweisungssatz durchrechnen, wirst du sehen, dass die Zeilen 3 bis 7 ebenfalls eine Wahrscheinlichkeit von 4/9 ergeben. Das bedeutet, wenn
Einstein recht hat und verborgene Variablen wie diese das Messergebnis vorbestimmen, gibt es keine Möglichkeit für Lucas
und Rihanna, jemals dasselbe Vorzeichen mit einer Wahrscheinlichkeit größer als 4/9 zu messen. Das ist die Bell-Ungleichung: P kleiner
oder gleich 4/9. Und wie wir zeigen werden, verletzen verschränkte Teilchen diese. Also um zu
sehen, was die Quantenmechanik vorhersagt: Sagen wir, Lucas misst entlang A. Zwei Dinge können passieren: Entweder misst er Spin up, also
würde Rihanna Spin down entlang A messen, oder er misst Spin down und Rihanna würde Spin up entlang A messen. Aber wir
wollen die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass Rihanna dasselbe Vorzeichen wie Lucas entlang einer beliebigen Achse ihrer Wahl misst, nicht nur A. Wenn
sie entlang B oder C misst, wird es etwas komplizierter. Es stellt sich heraus, dass
wenn du weißt, was Rihanna mit 100% Sicherheit entlang einer Richtung messen wird, du die Wahrscheinlichkeiten berechnen kannst,
dass sie up oder down entlang einer anderen Achse misst — mit ein wenig Geometrie.
Wenn dein Zustand immer Spin up entlang einer Achse misst, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, Spin up entlang einer anderen Achse zu messen,
gleich dem Quadrat des Kosinus des halben Winkels zwischen den beiden Achsen. Das ist etwas kompliziert, aber
ich zeige dir, was ich meine. Wenn Lucas Spin up entlang A misst, wissen wir mit 100% Sicherheit, dass Rihanna
Spin down messen würde, wenn sie entlang A misst. Das können wir mit einem Vektor
so darstellen. In diesem Fall sind die Winkel zwischen diesem Vektor und den beiden anderen Messachsen B und C jeweils
60°. Also ist die Hälfte davon 30° und der Kosinus von
30° ist hier dargestellt. Kosinus zum Quadrat von
30° gleich 3/4. Was nun, wenn Lucas Spin down
entlang A misst? Wir wissen, Rihanna würde Spin up entlang A messen, also können wir hier einen weiteren Vektor zeichnen. Nun
ist dieser Vektor, der dieses Wissen darstellt, 120° von jeder der beiden anderen Achsen B
und C entfernt. Also können wir denselben Geometrie-Trick anwenden, aber diesmal erhalten wir den Kosinus von
60°. Also Kosinus zum Quadrat von
60° gleich 1/4. Da Lucas gleich wahrscheinlich
Spin up und Spin down entlang A misst, müssen wir diese beiden Wahrscheinlichkeiten von Rihanna mitteln. Wir erhalten eine endgültige
Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass Rihanna dasselbe Vorzeichen wie Lucas misst, von 1/2. Also P
gleich 1/2 ist größer als 4/9, also ist Bells Ungleichung verletzt.
Das bedeutet, solange die Regeln der Quantenmechanik gelten, sind verborgene Variablen unmöglich. Jetzt können wir Qiskit und einen
IBM Quantencomputer verwenden, um die Bell-Ungleichung mit echten Quantenmessungen zu testen. Wir können die Spin-up- und
Spin-down-Zustände von Lucas' und Rihannas Teilchen auf die Null- und Eins-Zustände der Qubits im Quantencomputer abbilden. Wir
nehmen zwei Qubits, eines für Lucas' Teilchen und eines für Rihannas, und verschränken sie mit diesem Quanten-Circuit.
Die zwei Qubits werden also durch die zwei Leitungen q0 und q1 dargestellt, und diese Kombination
aus X-, Hadamard- und C-NOT-Gates erzeugt denselben verschränkten Zustand, den wir zwischen Lucas' und Rihannas Teilchen hatten. Jetzt
müssen wir jedes Qubit messen. Wir setzen Lucas' Messung auf entlang A, was wir als Z-Achse definieren. Dann kann Rihannas
Messung entlang A, B oder C sein, also brauchen wir drei separate Circuits für jeden dieser drei Fälle. Aber in diesem
Video machen wir nur einen. Du kannst zum Modul gehen, das in der Beschreibung verlinkt ist, für die vollständige Version. Wenn Rihanna entlang
B misst, sieht unser Circuit so aus, wobei RY eine Drehung um 120° ist, um
Rihannas Messachse zu ändern. Wir können das Qiskit-Primitive Sampler verwenden, um dieses Experiment viele Male durchzuführen und
Statistiken aus den resultierenden Messungen zu sammeln. Die beiden Spalten 0 0 und 1 1 repräsentieren die Male, in denen Lucas und
Rihanna dasselbe Vorzeichen gemessen haben, was das ist, woran wir interessiert sind. Also ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, beide Teilchen mit demselben
Vorzeichen zu messen, sehr nahe an 1/2. Das verletzt Bells Ungleichung. Das bedeutet,
dass die beiden Teilchen verschränkt sind. Jedes scheint irgendwie instantan das Ergebnis einer
Messung des anderen zu kennen. Es gibt immer noch etwas Uneinigkeit darüber, wie genau diese
Verschränkung zu interpretieren ist und was passiert, wenn man einen verschränkten Zustand misst. Aber diese Fragen sind eher philosophischer Natur. Die
Theorie ist an diesem Punkt ziemlich unbestreitbar. Verschränkung ist definitiv real, und wir wissen das dank Bell, seiner
Ungleichung und den vielen Physikern, die Experimente durchgeführt haben, um sie zu testen. Wenn du zu denjenigen
Physikern gezählt werden möchtest und deinen eigenen Bell-Test mit einem Quantencomputer durchführen willst, schau dir das Bell-Ungleichungs-Modul an,
das in der Beschreibung verlinkt ist. Danke fürs Zuschauen, und bis zum nächsten Mal.